on today's show we talk about heavy
things so watch out for the little ears
in the room
we'll be talking about childhood sexual
abuse we'll be talking about changing
your life
losing weight and becoming more
disciplined and we're going to talk
about cultural issues
and dealing with your brother's kids and
stepping up in your family
stay tuned
hey what up what up this is john with
the dr john dolone show i hope you're
doing well
hope you're treating people around you
nice hope people are treating you nice
hope you're taking care of yourself
exercising sleep and getting outside
i don't know man it may still be cold
where you are it can't make up its mind
here
we we had a snow day i would know i
almost said we literally had a snow day
but that would have been an annoying use
of an adverb there
no reason to add that because we did
have a snow day last week
and then today it's 111 degrees out here
so i don't know what's going on
but anyway on today's show we got a lot
going on i'm excited you're here
just as a reminder if you're new to or
if you're just
just as a reminder slash or if you're
new to this show there is no slash there
um we talk about mental health talking
about relationships you talk about
everything on the show
right we've gotten into education policy
and politics and health and well
everything that is going on in your life
in your heart and your mind and your
relationships
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
one
eight four four six nine three thirty
two ninety one or go to johndaloni.com
show fill out the form and we will get
you in
live and in person and i'd like to take
this moment
as we start the show to let kelly
zack james know i am dedicating my life
to one
thing that's not being a better husband
being a better parent
it's being on time and prepared at work
so zach just cheered so listen
today look look i've got notes
everything i'm ready to go
i don't even know what that's right it's
episode 82.
episode 82. some of us it takes a minute
some of it takes i don't know an annual
performance review
but some of us are working on it
does this include meetings why do you
have to why'd you have to be drinking
the haterade kelly we're
that's that's next week today it's about
the show
no it doesn't include meetings it just
includes this meetings are
fortunate you're unfortunate all right
so give me a call
1-844-693-3291 let's go to the phones
let's go to elise
and vancouver washington elise what's
going on how can i help
hi good morning or afternoon sorry hey
it's good to talk to you
yeah thank you for having me you betcha
so what's up um
well let's do a little background story
first
oh my anytime somebody's talking to the
background story usually it's a lot here
so
go for it yeah yeah okay so um
when i was seven my uh grandfather
sexually assaulted me okay yep um
so he was uh my next-door neighbor
growing up
my grandparents were and they're
actually still my parents next door
neighbors
um i'm 21 now i'm married i live about
30 minutes from them i have a
17 month old daughter who's my absolute
world awesome
and i just feel like i've never
gotten healing and
i you know i just i don't know now i'm
an adult and i have a daughter and i
realize
i need healing and something maybe
should have been done a little
differently and i'm just
needing advice on kind of where to start
where to go
yeah well first thank you for trusting
me with that i appreciate that
um and congratulations on your beautiful
little baby girl your husband's a good
guy
yes he's he's my absolute rock that's
awesome good for you
all right so take me back um not in
detail but take me back when you were
seven
so is this a one-time incident or was
over
a season what did you tell me about what
you experienced back then
um so it was a one-time incident
uh and i my mom could tell
i went up to my grandparents to drop off
something
and happen while i was there my grandma
was at work so it's just my grandpa at
home
and my mom could tell something was
wrong uh
you know as the day kind of went on and
so i eventually told her that day
my dad got home from work i told him and
they
called my grandparents and went up there
and talked to them and i never really
heard how that conversation went
um i kind of heard little snippets
throughout the years just
of like i heard you know my grandpa
didn't know what i was talking about my
grandma didn't believe me
and um did your parents believe you
yeah they just um
yeah i don't know i i think that they
just didn't know how to handle it so
have you have you ever uh have you ever
talked to your
parents like sat down mom dad now that
you're 21 i mean
have you ever had a conversation with
them say hey what happened that day i
went and told grandma grandpa what i
told you
it was a really really brave thing that
you
what you did as a seven-year-old really
brave and it doesn't usually happen that
way
which tells me you may have been one of
the rare kids that has a really
remarkable relationship with their
parents that you felt safe enough to do
that
um and then there's something
disorienting about
somebody that's safe when you believe
that they don't believe you
right or you don't know what happens
after that it just goes and you know
this disclosure this heavy thing goes
into a mist right
have you ever sit down and talk to him
about what happened
um no not really i just
i kind of uh i don't know
i i'm sandwiched between two boys my dad
you know would say things like elise
doesn't cry at least it's tough so
i kind of just didn't know how to i
didn't want them to know how much it
kind of bothered me and i remember
overhearing my mom talking on the phone
one time to
her sister and i i heard my grandpa's
first name and my name and then
she said something to the effect of well
she still brings it up every once in a
while so it's obviously still bothering
her and
it was like an internal switch just shut
off like
i was like i i don't want to talk about
it i don't want them to know what
bothers me
like i don't know so
no i i kind of just quit
talking about it so the idea that your
mom was talking to
your sisters her sister your aunt yeah
and their debate is i wonder if it's
still bothering her
right not are we gonna are we gonna go
visit dad in jail
not are we going to get to the bottom of
this but
i wonder if she's over it yet that's
gotta hurt huh
yeah yeah it did and i
i don't know i just like i said i kind
of felt a switch turn off i was like
i'm not going to open up i don't want to
talk about it
i hate that well and that
yeah that grin and barrett right that
that
becomes how you interact with trauma for
the rest of your life so
have you had things in the last 14 years
between that seven and 21 years that
that idea of grin and barrett has just
become of your modus operandi
the way you operate oh yeah oh yeah
i i kind of joke about this but it's
really serious how
um you know like i told you my dad said
you know elise doesn't cry well
i i did at night in my bed yeah she did
yeah
but uh meeting my husband i
i joked to him about i've never cried so
much in my life yeah
you know i found somebody i could just
you know those floodgates opened
yeah i imagine so you've got a 17 month
old now
and what you'll feel
i i'm projecting onto you right so i'm
i'm lumping you into
what a vast number of people in your
same situation
will experience over time is as your
daughter increasingly gets closer
to in and around that age you will feel
an anxiety you will feel and angst
you'll feel a
control need a paralysis you'll feel all
kinds of things
um increasingly as your brain begins to
recognize
her and that trauma right
and you are super wise to say well i
need to i need to get on top of this now
um so walk me through
your family situation now you say you
live half an hour there i'm assuming
this was never dealt with right they had
a one time conversation and
grandma and grandpa denied it
potentially and your parents never
talked to you about it and then we just
all moved on right
yeah um well i mean i was close to
that particular grandma growing up so i
would go up there sometimes weekly to
work on a sewing project or whatever and
i even
went to hawaii with those grandparents
for nine days
and nothing happened there um
it was more well
nothing like super serious but i i
remember telling my
my husband now my boyfriend then um i
just remember telling him like i feel
like he can't keep his hands off me
and there would be inappropriate
comments left and right
and i was just so uncomfortable and i i
just i was crying out like i just want
to go home
you know and i actually got married
later that year and
have kind of used the excuse of moving
30 minutes away that i don't have to see
him
so i want to free you from this at least
you don't have you don't need an excuse
right you don't need an excuse yeah
that person hurts you and one of the
most ex
like devastating and tragic way somebody
can hurt somebody else
and so you don't need an excuse right
you can just
feel fit from this point forward you
need no more excuses you are free
you don't do anything you don't want to
when it comes to
being in around that situation so is he
still alive
yeah yep has this ever come up with
other people do you have cousins or
ants that have have whispered around so
often this has
you know it kind of has a cloud that
goes with guys like this
um well okay so when this actually
happened
i heard about this couple years like
later um
that my you know my grandma didn't
believe me so she went around calling
aunts and uncles and you know saying why
why would she say this and
whatever so um one uh my dad is
the youngest of three boys so it was the
middle brother he had two kids
and uh so my grandparents would babysit
them and my parents kind of felt like
okay they're letting their little father
be
babysat you know so we should kind of
let them know
and let them make that decision so i
know that my parents did sit down with
uh an aunt of mine that so
she could know but i mean i could tell
you 14 kids names right now that he's
had access to since then oh my gosh
yeah so here's the thing um
i think the right thing to do is you got
to say something at this point does he
still have access to kids now
oh yeah yep yeah um there's
you know there's when when you know
about something here's a big deal
so one of the things that's taken from
you is and i'm i'm
using this as a moment to teach people
listening okay when you experience
this type of sexual trauma this type of
sexual abuse one of the one of the
things that's stolen from you is your
autonomy
right your your freedom your right to
make a decision about
you right and so when i'm meeting with
somebody
privately when i'm talking to somebody
behind closed doors who's experienced
this and they're trying to figure out
what to do next i always want to make
sure
one important thing that they know they
control the narrative from this point
forward
they control if what happens they
control
who finds out all those things you have
to own that control
right where it gets messy
and where i'm going to tell you i don't
know you can you control your story
but if there's other people involved
then we have to get involved and say hey
this is somebody who has a history of
doing this before
before they have access to hurt kids now
and as a community member i've got to
get involved right as a community member
your husband's got to get involved as a
community member fill in the blank
people have to
cut off access to children to people who
hurt children which is what your
granddad did
right and that's where you find yourself
so what do you want to do in terms of
healing what kind of he when you have a
picture in your mind of what healing
looks like what do you want that to be
um i
would like to sit down with my parents
and my older brother he's got three
young kids
so they want to sit down with us at the
same time because they have feelings on
this too
when i sit down talk to my parents and
say you know
this happened 14 years ago yeah but i
don't feel like
it's kind of i don't know it's just sat
there and festered like nothing
yes of course it's because it's just
awful trauma yes
hey listen yeah it when you say things
like it just sat there and festered
i don't want you to feel like you're
something's wrong with you
right yeah i don't you feel like you're
broken or you're screwed up
this is not yes this has somebody
poisoned you
right and then people are like wow when
is she gonna
be that person yeah yeah well it is
yeah it is yeah what does your brother
say about it
um it's really it's bothered him
especially since
i kind of brought it up to him and there
they want to make it clear to my parents
to know that their kids are not allowed
around
them good for your brother man they're
actually going to
meet with the pastor on wednesday night
and get some insight
on how to talk to our parents too so
good for your brother
good for your brother so here's here's
the way to move forward with your
parents okay
um you feel of course feel free to have
that meeting on wednesday but here's
here's the way you go for your parents i
want you to write down what you want to
tell them
and it's probably going to be real real
hard okay
if you trust your husband enough and
this isn't an indictment of him or your
marriage or anything
if you trust him enough read him what
you're going to say to your parents
so you can have gone through at one time
you've spoken these words out
sometimes when you say the words out
loud especially in front of people who
should have protected you
right who should have kept you from
going on a nine-day vacation
and all that other awfulness after um
your granddad did what he did um
sometimes
saying that becomes so overwhelming when
you put into the universe the first time
so yeah say something out loud if you
can if you can't that's okay
it's okay and then i want you to be
extremely clear your parents have
lost they gave in they cashed in
there i don't even know like what did
you even say like without just getting
really really angry with them they they
chose not to
protect you that's a decision they made
you do not have you need to be
respectful and a person of dignity not
for them but for you
okay that you are not responsible for
their feelings you are not responsible
for their drama you're not responsible
if they come back and say you know what
you're going to do
if you say this out loud if you call the
police if you do
you don't own any of that because they
abdicated that right when they didn't
take care of you when you were a young
child
and now you are in the position to be
the grown-up here and you are you're an
adult you got your own kid you're
married you're you know you're an adult
now
and you're having to clean up the mess
of at least three if not
four other adults and more right whoever
else has been a part of not saying
anything
your aunts all include them so that that
number gets big
as a part of the healing process you're
gonna get rage filled
against your parents against your aunts
and uncles against people who didn't
come out and defend that seven-year-old
little girl
okay that's natural that's a part of
this my hope is that you can
you can lean towards forgiveness at some
point but at this point
you are in control okay
there is no soft pedaling this with mom
and dad there is no we'll let us
we're gonna nope they cashed that in 14
years ago
they had 14 years to protect their baby
and they didn't
14 years yep
so when you imagine do you have a
picture in your head of your granddad in
jail
do you have a picture of him having to
move away from the neighborhood like
what do you want to happen on the back
end
what does healing look like to you i
think
i'd at least like a
uh no contact order um awesome oh he
can't
contact me or my family and i mean this
should have happened
when this whole incident happened in the
first place but yep
you know i i do i do plan to call the
police department and
file you know give my uh testimony or
whatever and
i don't know at least register as a sex
offender or something well and
what will happen is when you make that
that that referral to the police
you'll get trained investigators that
will then go talk to the kids he's had
access to
not moms and dads who know how to squash
their kids and how to make people
uncomfortable and make them feel scared
but trained investigators who can go in
and have a like a true investigation
right
get real experts asking real hard
questions in ways that kids can
understand
and then they'll get to the bottom of it
and maybe
fingers crossed this is a one-time
incident
and there's he's gonna have access to 17
kids and 16 of them are going to say we
don't it was it's all been great
it's all been great right yeah that
would be it it feels like an anomaly
right yeah let's all hope for that of
course
um but at the end of the day you're
protecting those kids out but you've got
to go through this process
for you right and i want you to know
right now
at least i'm proud of you for
choosing to take this on i'm proud of
you for having the courage
um proud of you for having the courage
to lean on somebody lean
your husband in this process and i'm
proud of you for
saying i needed the oldest because my
daughter's headed
right she's going to be walking in my
footsteps and
i'll be damned if i'm going to let her
walk right into the same mess
good for you good for you so here's what
i want you to do
please please call us back and let us
know how the conversation with your
parents goes
good for your brother for saying i'm
getting um i'm team elise all the way
uh good for him sometimes we get
brothers and sisters who want to
separate themselves from this and he's
all team
elise which tells me he may know
something too
right he may know something too and good
for you good for you call us back let us
know the conversation goes
if you're interested i'd love to have
you back on the show to walk us through
how the conversation went and what your
next steps were
how you felt through that unfortunately
what you are experiencing is what
millions and millions of people across
this country experience
what millions and millions of people
across the world experience every day
i'm sick of it i'm sick of it and i'm so
proud of you
for saying not my daughter and i'm not
carrying this around anymore i'm putting
this crap down it's good for you good
for you thank you so much for your call
elise
and by the way if you know of somebody
who's hurting kids this is talking to
the listener now if you know of people
who are hurting kids
you got an obligation to get in the
middle of it and say stop you got to you
got to make that phone call
you got to make that phone call let the
investigators do their investigation
quit taking your kids around that stuff
and parents if a seven-year-old comes to
you
if a nine-year-old comes to you in that
moment of vulnerability and says help
oh my gosh help them
help them help them
you're all they've got help them
all right thank you so much for that
call elise all right i'm gonna take a
left turn here
and i'm going to take a big deep breath
i'm going to make no weird noises
and then we're going to go right to
megan in owensboro kentucky
megan what's going on how can i help hey
dr john i'm really excited to talk to
you i'm a big fan of your show
i am a big fan of yours megan so what's
up thanks for calling
hey yeah no problem um so
something i've struggled with for years
is just kind of feeling like um
i have a disconnect between my mind and
my body
when it comes to specifically weight
loss and fitness
mentally intellectually i know what i
should do i know what has worked for me
in the past
but then just getting my body to do it
is like a whole different battle that i
just haven't been able like
it's just one area of my life that i
feel like i've never really
been able to master hmm very cool thanks
for thanks for being vulnerable man that
one's a hard one
that one's really tough to say out loud
so um good for you
so how far back does this go how far
have you struggled
uh or used the word battle how long have
you been at war with your body
my whole life i mean i remember
when i was like in kindergarten you know
asking my mom why do i have a
big belly and the other kids don't and
you know when i look back at pictures i
was just a normal
yeah like chunky little kid but like
normal you know
and um who taught you that you were
chunky
i don't i don't know i mean it probably
came from somewhere but i think just
you know looking at other kids like i
was just aware that i was bigger than
them and
people would always say my dad's a big
man he's just a large man
and when i was i mean as long as far
back as i can remember
toddler people would say oh my gosh she
looks just like her daddy you know and i
would just be like i don't want to have
you know like i really internalize that
and um
and then you know i am objectively i am
overweight like
i am yeah um and i mean if you look i
know bmi is not the best measure but
according to bmi like i'm morbidly obese
you know but i'm not
i'm not lazy i don't binge eat i'm not
you know it's
i don't know i don't i don't identify
with the stereotypes of a person who's
morally obese but then i think
okay but i am you know and
i don't know why like i don't know why i
can't
why you can't shake it yeah either
either
mentally get over it and just say okay
that's my body and like
this is just who i am or physically
actually
do the work to fix to change it
not fix it it's not you know yeah so
change it
yeah there you go ah look at you look at
you using your not a machine language
that was awesome so um
i i love you're here and so i just want
to speak it out loud
i know that you're saying these words i
still feel like you're feeling them and
i want to just say it to you
there is a difference between
looking at the health numbers right like
you can't deny those
those numbers right if they if you are
obese your obese
and then there's the all of the moral
morality
right all of the characterological
things we've attached to that right
that must mean then that you are lazy
and don't care about yourself and hate
whatever fill in the blank right
and so i want there i want you to have a
separation there
right i want we can deal with the
reality that you
want to be healthy you want to be
somebody who is a steward of
their body you only get one right and
i want you to not walk around
with the with the identity part that
culture says you're all of these things
because of this
right you may be working
your butt off right and we just have to
channel
that energy somewhere else
you may be dealing with childhood
traumas you may have been
told this your whole life and your way
to make sure nobody could hurt you
was to stay away there's a thousand
reasons why right
at the end of the day as you're asking
how do you do the thing that you know
you should be doing right
yes you said things have worked in the
past so have you
yo-yoed before have you have you gone
after this before
yeah i've been on some type of a diet or
workout or whatever plan since i was
like
i think i joined my audrey's when i was
12. oh no
yeah but that tells me that your parents
were involved in this
well i think did you have somebody
telling me you're a pudgy little girl
or hey we need to you need to eat some
more vegetables i mean did you get that
kind of talk growing up
no it came from me it was um
it was i don't want to look like this
anymore
and how can we fix it and of course you
know
my parents also were on diets and so
they were like well we can
we can all do it together you know just
support it if not
you need to lose weight it was just like
hey let's all try to be healthier
together
and um you know my dad was going to wait
watchers with me so it was that kind of
thing
um it was just a thing that was present
in our house
um and i don't
nobody meant anything
negative to me about it you know i'm i'm
generally a very confident person
so like my parents it's never been
anything like that it's just
cool um you know so yeah i've done
every kind of diet uh and and in
my adulthood i have realized like okay
diets
quote-unquote diets are not going to
work for me i just really need to find
ways to incorporate
healthy lifestyle it's not a diet bro
it's a lifestyle yeah
yeah everything feels so extreme when it
comes to a diet
yeah i don't want to live a life where i
can't eat a carb i don't want to live a
life where i have to
you know measure out everything that i
eat in a measuring cup like
i don't want to count some arbitrary
points that somebody made up
so yeah i've done all that i used to be
pretty into like
lifting weights and going to the gym and
stuff but
that was kind of driven by other things
like
i was pretty lonely for a you know
number of years
um so the gym felt like a way to
socialize kind of and just get out of
the house yeah so that was
almost unhealthy in the opposite
direction of
yeah now i'm just like lifting weights
for two hours a day and i was pretty fit
at that point
but i can't i liked that body but i
can't go back to that lifestyle
so what do you what do you want
i just want to feel better in my body
and feel better about myself
and and what do you think it's going to
take to get there
you think it's a combination of
psychological and phys physical
um all right let me ask let me ask it
this way
what weighs on you more what hurts you
more
your physical your physical or the fact
that you've tried a bunch and you
haven't been successful
um
i think it's partially the fact that i
i do the comparison game where i'm like
but i eat healthier than the average
person
and i'm pretty active and yet
here i am yeah meanwhile you know i know
this
i know several other people who eat way
less healthier
than i do and like are less active than
me yeah but your biggest thing you can't
do anything about that a different way
right you can't do anything about them
have you ever been to a doctor i think
that's what bothers me the most
have you ever been to a doctor and got a
full physical workout
yes okay and what is the recommendation
healthy
all that stuff okay so i've had my
hormones tested and all that stuff soon
okay so here's here's my global
recommendation
and i would also recommend that
a couple i got a couple different things
here okay so i'm gonna roll
into some things just one after the
other here and feel free to
capture this when it comes out you don't
have to write anything down if you want
to write stuff down cool great
um here's a question i want you to ask
yourself you don't have to do it on the
show but here's a question i want you to
really dig
into in your soul okay i want you to
ask yourself do you really
want to change your behavior
do you want to change your quote unquote
change your body
or do you like the idea of change
and those are two radically different
things because
one is do i really want to change i'm
going to start today
now i'm not even going to wait till
tomorrow i'm going to start with today
right
um and then others is i really really
like the idea of being a medical doctor
i'm just not i'm not that smart i didn't
go to med school
i didn't fill in the blank right i like
the idea of that but i don't like it
enough that i'm going to actually change
it
and those are two radically different
things so if
if you really want to change then you go
to the next thing right
and that is this no matter what you said
i don't like counting i don't like
eating specific ways i just want to eat
healthier than the average person
i just want to be more active the
average person and then i also want to
look like the average person
and looking back over the arc of your
life that hasn't been how it's played
out
what i know about me and i know about my
family and i know about
my physiology and my genetics is i have
to do things differently than the
average person
when it comes to sleep when it comes to
nutrition when it comes to what i eat
because the way my body is put together
the way my physiology is put together
i can't be like the average person and
that's just been something i had to
accept
i have people in my family across my
lineage who have chosen i don't really
care about that
so i'm not going to accept that i've had
to do that which means
i've got to be really uncomfortable when
it comes to saying no to things
to counting things right know this going
in
if you really want to make a radical
life change and you're talking about
change that you remember when you were
a kindergartner can it be done one
million percent and i've got full
uh i got a hundred percent confidence in
you megan
if you wanna do this but you just gotta
know that's gonna be super uncomfortable
for a season
simply because you are changing the way
your brain works
and our brains change every day in
response to all different sorts of
things
but you're gonna have to change the way
you talk to yourself you're gonna have
to change the way you look to other
people
you're gonna have to get comfortable
with being uncomfortable when it comes
to
counting things doing things differently
being annoyed that you
are experiencing discomfort or pain in a
certain season
but it's all towards something right
which is this why
this change of i'm somebody who can
stick to goals and make them happen i'm
somebody who
is not going to be have a doctor tell me
hey you're unhealthy to the point that
we're worried about what your future is
going to be like right
and so here's another big one people in
your life
are going to lean on you to go back to
the way you are
the more change you enact the taller you
begin to walk in your case the more
weight you shed
the more people are going to say hey
just let's do this just one time um
we really thought you were beautiful
before why are you doing
oh no just come on over we're going to
eat this i'm going to order this for us
don't worry about it
people want their homeostasis they want
things to be the same
they don't like it when people around
them change even when it's for good
even when they know it's the best thing
for them because it changes their life
too
and so when you enter into this like a
radical life change
you got to know it's going to be
uncomfortable and you've got to know
that people in your life are going to
push back on
you if you are someone who's lonely and
this i've experienced as myself
then it gets really hard because you
feel like your options are limited and
what i want to tell you is when you
begin to work on yourself and you stand
a little bit taller
the people who are ride or die megan are
going to be there
and those who are not those who use you
for other purposes in their life
will just fall by the wayside and you
have to do the work of get people around
you
okay so here's a couple of things i want
you to do number one i want you to write
down
what you actually want not just i want
to be i want to
not look like this i want to be you got
to be real
real specific okay
and before you get into the goals i want
to weigh this much i want to be
like i want to be able to wear this size
before you get into that stuff i want
you to
be very specific about the kind of
person you're going to be
right i'm the kind of person i'm the
kind of person who
really takes care of my body i'm the
kind of person who is super kind i'm the
kind of person who talks
well about everyone especially and
including myself
i don't let anybody talk negative about
me and i don't talk negative about me
and i'm telling you megan
last night my wife said hey i'm putting
a stop
to somebody talking so bad about my
husband john and it's you
and i've seen you doing it the last two
weeks and enough so enough stop
right so i'm the pro at negative
self-talk the pro
right nobody talks to delony worse than
i do
even commenters on youtube don't talk
about me as bad as i do right
and to the point that my wife had to
step in and say i'm not letting somebody
talk about my husband so you're gonna
have to change all those things away
around the way you talk to yourself then
you're gonna have to write it down right
and then i want you to start making
things easier so you don't have to plan
it
what does that mean you're gonna have to
do the hard annoying work of
if exercise is a part of your plan
everyone should be moving
you gotta put those things up by your
bed that night right
so that in the morning you don't think
you just go into automated mode
and you just go make it happen right you
just go make it happen
uh if you got a meal prep you got a meal
prep right if you can't have certain
foods in your house that's the way my
house
is by the way then you can't have
certain foods in your house when people
drop cookies off you have to say thank
you you're so wonderful and you got to
throw in the trash
right you got to put them in the garbage
right you got to be extreme
here's the next thing you gotta have at
least one person but preferably a group
of people that will hold you accountable
right now if i pull up my phone i would
be able to show you i've got a day
counter app
on how many days i haven't had sugar and
i have to text it every day to my buddy
who is a active navy seal
and if i skip a day between now and my
goal date
the workout i have to do megan is
unpleasant
all right i've put i've put a barrier in
my life i've also told my wife i've told
my family i've told my friends
a couple of days ago i got a i went did
a speech for somebody and they gave me
like a uh
i don't know it's probably a gallon
sized jar it was in that jar megan
can i tell you what was in it it was
filled with layers of marshmallows
gummy candy marshmallows gummy worms
marshmallow lucky charms marshmallows
dude like big ones
on top it was just it was i don't know
what being addicted to heroin is like
but it's gotta be like that
right and they asked me to partake with
them and i had to look at them in front
of a group of people and say i can't
today
and they all cheered and it was all blah
blah i wanted it so bad
right so you're gonna have to get
accountability people and then
you're not going to like this you're
going to have to track yourself you're
going to have to keep some sort of
progress whether it's a
photograph whether it is i think a scale
is
generally on the whole completely
useless it's stupid
but having some way to say i got half of
one percent better today
i'm not comparing myself to anybody on
instagram any of my friends any of my
family members i'm just comparing myself
to me
and today i got a little bit better
today it went flat but i slept all night
and so tomorrow i'm gonna write so some
way you can keep track of it
and then let me ask you this what is
your big temptation in the world
like if you had a thing that makes you
feel okay
that helps you numb helps you hide what
would it be it could be anything i'm
just asking what is it
um i mean probably food
okay like if i'm honest with myself yeah
yeah like so
walk me through a scenario your boss
calls
and um she calls you and she says hey
you had this thing done you got it
turned in and it's not what i was hoping
for
i expect more of you and she says on
monday we're gonna
you me are gonna talk this isn't what i
was expecting
and she of course she waits till 4 30 on
a friday afternoon to call you
and she hangs up what do you do what's
your next thing
um it depends on the day of course but i
mean probably my first reaction would be
to go
for a long walk okay outside awesome
um but if it's you know
not nice weather or something like that
or there's some obstacle to me going for
a walk
it would probably be like the largest
diet coke i could get my hands on and
like
some cheese fries or something something
fried and cheesy
and a huge diet coke because the diet
coke washes it all away right
did you know i literally asked i just
definitely love diet coke
i do too don't take that away from me dr
johnson no you can't have it but
i'm not gonna be the person to take that
a real doctor will but yeah you gotta
get rid of that too
but here's the thing here's what i want
you to do and this was a
eye-opening experiment for me i had when
i wrote down here's the kind of person i
am
i'm a person that honors my body i'm a
person who's going to be around for my
grandkids
and i'm going to be able to roll around
on the floor that so i tried to paint my
picture 50 years out and work myself
back
here was a big deal is to catch myself
right before i go do something that i
know is not good for me
right whether it's call somebody or look
at something or eat some whatever the
thing is in our lives right
that i'm just going to go i'm going to
look at a couple of more youtube clips
before i head home to see my kids right
i'm going to
whatever the thing is is to stop really
quick
and say what is my brain protecting me
from right now so in that scenario
if you say i gotta go for a walk that's
actually one of the most healthiest
behaviors you can possibly have to deal
with stress and distraction i mean
stress and somebody dropping something
on you so good for you
but if you're like me i reach for junk
food for candy
i wish i could reach for the the cheese
fries man they sound so good
um but once i start to stick my hand in
a candy jar i've got to stop and say
what is my brain protecting me from and
it's that discomfort and once i call
that discomfort
out i put out in the universe like hey
my boss just clowned on me for doing
less than my best then i'm busted right
it is what it is right
and then i can move on from it um and
then here's the last thing i want to
to leave you with okay is
i want you to remember this phrase and
never forget it
don't forget to remember don't forget to
remember
right when we have patterns of behavior
especially ones that have been
in ingrained in our minds since we were
kindergarteners right
and then we get in those things get
reinforced with emotion and shame and
frustration
and anger and all those things in a big
loop-de-loop-de-loopty-loop-de-loop
right loneliness all those things pile
on themselves
when those get ingrained we often just
forget
our default response right i'm just
going to reach for that bathtub of diet
coke i'm going to reach for
candy i'm going to reach for another
drink another drink on the drink i'm
going to go call an old girlfriend fill
in the blank
when we do that we off that default
setting man that dopamine
just shower hits it our midbrain and
we're off to the races
that's when you got to pause and say
don't forget to remember not that i can
stop it here
don't forget to remember how good it
feels when i wake up without a hangover
don't forget to remember how bad i feel
after i hang up with somebody i know i
shouldn't have been on the phone with
don't forget to remember when i
close my computer don't go to any more
youtube clips and i just go play with my
kids
don't forget to remember how good it
feels when i don't eat a bunch of trash
at night and then i can't sleep and then
i start that whole cycle over again
right don't forget to remember over time
that that you'll you'll move up your
decision-making tree
from the future to right now to the
present but man that phrase gets me
through so much
i got a i got a car full of crap just
junk papers trash
don't forget to remember how good it
feels to get inside of a clean truck man
and i'll stop
get all my junk out right i'm not gonna
see that wrapper there i'll just get a
die coke put it in the thing and then
head inside
put it in the cup holder don't forget to
remember right don't forget remember so
here's here's what i want you to do
i want you to get this youtube clip and
i want you to start with writing down
who you're going to be
i want you to get some accountability
people if you're going to make some
major transitions in your life that have
been there since you're in kindergarten
you've got to get a professional to walk
by you especially initially
start with a counselor start there let
them know hey
i'm not looking to get to a certain
weight i'm not looking to get to a
certain size i'm looking to become a
person who
loves themself inside and out
i'm looking to become a person who is
disciplined and ready to rock and roll
i am looking to become somebody who
i can count on and then the body stuff
is just
ancillary it will come right and you
will unwind some of those default
settings your heart is good you've got
great people around you who love you
you've got good instincts right and now
it's just a matter of shifting those
things
here's two books i want you to get get
atomic habits by james clear
which is one of the best books on that
topic i've ever read
it's it's an excellent read and then
you're going to laugh
but i want you to pick up discipline
equals freedom by jocko
discipline equals freedom it's written
in like 88-point font
it's direct into the point and you
cannot mince he doesn't mince words
right i want you to get those two books
and those books will walk you through
step by step
here's how to change your life from the
inside out right
here's how to change your life from the
inside and by the way if you're
listening to this and you're like
oh man she just needs to fill in the
blank shut up
nobody leave negative comments on here
about
about my new friend here megan about her
weight about her
lack shut up everybody shut up nobody
knows what other people are walking
through
right nobody leave encouraging comments
about her or leave nothing at all keep
your drivel and idiotic moronic
self-superiority thumbs down whatever
keep them to yourself she doesn't need
them i don't want them
she is somebody who's saying i'm going
to make a change in my life i'm going to
start today
i'm going to start tonight i'm going to
read i'm going to get connected with
people i'm going to connect with a
professional i'm going to start this
journey
of creating new identities good for you
megan good for you
good for everybody whether it's weight
whether it is
i want to write a book whether it is i
want to get stronger whether i want to
be a better dad i want to be a better
husband
whatever it is you start with writing it
down
it's gonna be uncomfortable who am i
gonna be thank you so much for your call
megan once you get on this journey i
want you to give us a call back keep us
updated and we'll keep our listeners
updated you
are brave you are vulnerable and you're
a hero good for you all right let's take
one more call
let's go to bobby in oshkosh
bobby what's going on man watch what's
happening dr john
i do not know my brother what about you
what's going on oh man it's
it's septic
hey man it's better than being bored
right so hey tell me how can i help
all right so um it's been a little over
a year now
since my brother and sister-in-law have
lost their kids my parents currently
have them
and it's kind of put a strain on i guess
you could say
the balance of the family because
everybody's gotta you know
kind of juggle his kids that are now
living with my parents
so you're did they get taken away court
order is there addiction or abuse or
something
uh it was uh it was drugs and abuse okay
but they're in a program right now to
try to get them back and so do your
parents have full custody or they just
got temporary custody they just gave
them to the nearest relative
they were well they were trying to go
for full custody but
they were told that this shouldn't i
guess take
long so they have i guess temporary
custody right now are you is your
brother and
your sister-in-law are they are they
working the plan are they being
um are they not they well
currently just just got enrolled into
the uh
that parenting class okay and they're
still doing their uh
alcohol classes or drug classes okay so
they're at the very beginning of working
any sort of plan right
yes okay all right so what's your
question ma'am
um so i mean because i'm the oldest
the next oldest brother um you know in
my culture it tends to fall down that
you know
everybody else and family goes well you
know you're the oldest brother next
oldest brother so you know
protect me like their dad so you know if
anything comes down you know like
i get you know the kids i want not to
sound bad but like pawned off on me okay
or
you know i get like some bad enough
remarks where they're like you know you
should be watching them you know birth
like
from my sister's or younger brothers
it's like you know you've got more time
to watch them
so the rest of your family members your
brothers and sisters
are on you because your parents have
taken these kids and you're not taking
them so you're saying
well that i'm not helping okay but i'm
not helping you enough
okay
and so what's your question uh is it
selfish for me maybe because i mean i
got you know a high school kid
a middle school kid and i i have a one
year old a one and a half year old
now brother yeah they're all over the
place
yeah yeah good for you and uh my
brother's kids are
uh range from three to eleven okay
and you know my kids uh my oldest she's
been danced after school so she's got
like confident
now that kova is calming down a little
bit you know they have
you know practice a couple times a week
competition on weekends
um so you know and we like to you know
go out
and you know travel go hiking and stuff
sure um last
summer we kind of felt the strain on
that because you know the kids are over
i don't have a big enough vehicle to
transport everybody would be driving two
cars
so so
why why i understand the cultural
pressure i don't understand it but i
i can sympathize with the
you've got extraneous cultural pressures
why do you care what other people are
saying if you can't do it you can't do
it
or is there a party that knows i can i'm
just gonna have to change my life
i can but yeah i would have to change my
life okay
so do you live next to your your parents
do you
live within proximity to these kids uh
we're about like 15 minute drive apart
okay so pretty close right have your
parents come to you and asked you for
help
they've asked uh everybody okay um but
obviously they have said a little more
to me saying you know because i am your
brother and i get it you know my
nieces and nephews they like coming over
here too but sure
how many brothers and sisters you have
uh
three sisters and four brothers
okay so you've got three other brothers
who are in the picture right
yes okay so
again without fully knowing the the
cultural ins and outs right and i and i
that is not something to be discounted
that's something to be highly respected
and to not just slough off right and
roll your eyes at
if i'm you what i would do is call a
meeting of all brothers and sisters
because one of the things that divides
families up is the one sister calls the
other sister who calls another brother
who calls mom
and makes little comments like well i
don't know why he's not helping as much
as so and so and i would be
and then dad makes a passive aggressive
comment to you
and then it blows up in your mind and
then you does that make sense it just
gets this whole
toxic you know britney spears toxic mess
right so here's what i've got yeah i'd
call a meeting of all brothers and
sisters do they live in it close enough
to you
where y'all could all get in a room
together or at least
get on the same side i mean every
everybody's within at least a proximity
of like an hour and a half
i love it so here's what i'm doing if
i'm you i'm calling a meeting
all brothers and sisters mom and dad all
of them
except for my brother who's working his
program he stays out of this mess
right he cashed his vote in um for the
time being
say mom and dad need help i know that
i'm the oldest here
and a lot of this technically falls on
me so
i'm telling you here's what i can do
all of us have to step up here and help
mom and dad can't do all this on their
own
everybody's pitching in and here's what
that's going to look like from me
i want everyone else to be open and
ready to help
and then you're going to take all the
drama out of the room you're going to
take all the gossip nonsense out of the
room you're going to take all the oh my
gosh oh my gosh
you take all that crap out and put every
call everyone out on the table
and say and you go first say here is
what i can do
i cannot take full custody of these kids
or i can
i cannot drive them around everywhere
they can or i can whatever you can or
can't do
the second thing is i want you to begin
to think in terms for your kids
not how many dance recitals are they
gonna miss
right not how many soccer things or how
what not in that way but start to look
at
what kind of dad am i modeling for them
what kind of
grown am i modeling for them
into who they are gonna become as
grown-ups
right and i can't answer that question
for you
but i'll put it to you in an unfair way
is that cool i'm gonna put it real
direct
do you want them in 10 years as when
they begin to have kids and figure out
who they're going to be
do you want them to be the parents who
say i will never miss a dance recital
or i want to be i want to be parents who
never miss a dance recital
or i want to be parents who if there's a
child in need
i've got it not to the expense of but to
the inclusion of
right not at the expense of but everyone
gets a ride
you know what i mean and so i think
there's probably a middle ground here i
think you've
backed yourself into a corner because
you're pissed off at your brother
you're annoyed at him you're mad that
suddenly you've got to step up and take
care of somebody else's mess
and that's frustrating and annoying
especially dude with a one-year-old in
the house i don't even know what day it
was when i had a one-year-old at my
house right
and it's annoying and the only way to
cut through that annoying
frustrating is just to say
i'm big brother i'm calling a meeting
here's what i can do
i'm not going to apologize for what i
can't do here's what i can do
the rest of us need all you all need to
step up we're going to come up with an
orderly fashion here
we're going to have people on call
people who can babysit we're going to
we're going to map this out
so it's not just this ongoing gushy ushi
thing
and kids there's gonna be a few things
we don't do because we're the kind of
people
who help our family out
and family i'm gonna take care of my
kids we're gonna have a family only
thing this weekend
because i'm the kind of dad that really
doubles down on my children
and you're gonna have to find that that
that
uh really messy middle here
it's not either or it is super
frustrating and it's also the right
thing
and the your family is lacking
leadership and that's when you get a
chance to step up bobby
that's when you get a chance to step up
here's what i want you to do i want you
to call that meeting
but before you do sit with your wife
come up with a
plan here's what we can do and it may be
do we get a one-year-old we can do
nothing except survive
and then in about six months we'll be
able to step up or no we've got some
capacity we can help
our 14 year old can babysit our 13 year
old ken fell in the blank
call the meeting and i want you to call
me back and let me know how that meeting
goes
my guess is everyone's going to exhale
because somebody finally took the reins
and said
here's the way this is going to be we're
all going to move forward there and
hopefully your brother
is going to watch your leadership your
brother is going to start working his
programs with
your sister-in-law they're going to get
their crap together
they're going to start getting connected
they're going to get well they're going
to get on a new road
to sobriety and then they're going to be
able to get the kids back and that's
what we all want right
thank you so much for your call brother
we're rooting for you man
and i'm i'm just so proud of you for
being the guy that's going to step
up and do what's right here all right so
as we wrap up today's show
let's see here let's go to man
i almost i made a horse noise i almost
got through the whole show
what an idiot i almost got through the
whole show without making a hoarse noise
at least you realize that you're growing
is that what i'm proud of yes i told you
as soon as i called it out you would
start noticing you're doing it and
you are now i'm embarrassed man i never
wanted to be a horse
all right so as we wrap up today i just
that's a strange
life goal to not be a horse but alas
here we go all right so
as we wrap up today's show we're going
to take you back to 2017 with one of my
favorite rappers
on planet earth it's office 2017
album entitled crooked the song is by
propaganda
and it's called gentrify it's so great
and he goes like this and when you see
them billboards yelling cash for homes
gentrify they're fixing a double your
rent in a construction zone
gentrify they slick but be slicker help
me welcome the hipsters
microbu coffee shop trader joel's whole
foods
trader joe's whole foods gentrified baby
man them gastro pubs and clean streets
ain't good enough they want yours
despite your crime rate y'all got prime
real estate
continuing columbus and they're coming
for your porch and they plant the flag
like that's my land i licked it brother
it's just business your economy could
use a booth a boost
and you know the truth you're on
unemployment through the roof
why ain't you cheerleading why you feel
a kind of way
boy you fixing not fit in the own in the
hood you was
made in we locals we loyal we hopeful we
home
and when you see them billboards yelling
cash for homes
gentrify propaganda what a record that
crooked record is
this has been the dr john dolone show
[Music]